hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm have some really cool
updates wanted to share with everyone
just so you kind of know what's going to
be happening in the future the first
thing is around the website we're going
to completely redo the website we're
going to rebrand it we're going to
redesign it and build it from the ground
up with some features and
functionalities that people been asking
for for quite a long time so excited
about that that's going to be later this
year another thing that's going to be
really cool is building a chess app from
the down of time people have asked hey
when are you gonna actually build a
chess app we want that so that's
definitely what I'm doing before that
though I hadn't built a chess at before
so I thought it'd be pretty cool to
build something a little less complex
than chest but still pretty fun to play
and so I just released my first appt
yesterday and the title of that is nine
square frenzy it's tic-tac-toe but it's
on steroids it's way more complicated
than you would possibly think
tic-tac-toe could be but it's super fun
completely free to play there are no
add-ons in the game so you can't even
pay money with this app if you try to
but I do think it would be cool to get
more people playing just to see if I'm
any good at creating apps at all and
also think it's a pretty cool game so
going to have a little giveaway here
their levels in this game 9 squared
frenzy and you can just go to nine
square frenzy calm you can search for in
the stores but you can just come here on
your mobile device or tablet depending
on what you're using click on one of
these and it will actually take you so
you can download it here but what I'm
going to do is I'm going to give away
five year membership so as many of y'all
know on the chess website com there is
memberships you can do monthly or you
can do yearly so I'm going to give away
five year memberships for free so the
first five people that get to level 21
on nine square frenzy now this launched
yesterday I went ahead and took a
screenshot of the leaderboard first
place right now is myself KGB 3384 I got
to level 23 so far so this is just to
show hey you actually can get to 21 this
is a legitimate thing i didn't put some
crazy level out there that no one could
get to so I definitely expect people to
get there
but it's also extremely hard I'm not
gonna lie this is a very complicated
game some of y'all may be thinking Kevin
it's it's tic-tac-toe there's no way I'm
gonna go ahead and tell you this is a
very complicated tic-tac-toe game but
it's completely free so you can check it
out let me know what you think again the
first five people that get to level 21 I
will get a free your membership if you
just email me your handle to the chess
website at gmail com that is my email
address you could just let me know your
handle and what device you're using if
you're on an android or an Apple device
you can let me know that in the email
the chess website calm and I'll have all
this information below in the comments
section just so y'all can see that as
well but good luck on the app let me
know what you guys think I was looking
for ways to get better at app building
so that when I do build the chess app
will be the greatest chess at pepper and
good luck in the contest again first
five people will win a free year
membership so thanks for watching check
out the app and i'll see you guys next
time but